viewer discretion is advised good
afternoon everybody and welcome to the
sunday Sun sets of fari acquired
contemplation of the week that was and
the week that is to come we have some
starlings they're a mixed flock of
Greater blue eared
and Cape glossies my name is James Henry
I'm waiting for the strap has ever been
strap do you think to have been strap
did ah good and our on camera today
sends on keys who is wearing a shirt at
the magnificence of which I can barely
describe to you she has a lion
underneath and occasional Tillis tree on
it and it is in the manner of well water
I suppose would call here on Mandela
shirt wouldn't you correct style
it even has tassels underneath it it
really is a thing of them haute couture
I think that's the correct term we also
have David key to joining us on this
vehicle on the other car we have got
Steve or I think he's heading towards
Tandy being filmed by Sebastian and on
foot today we have got Ralph
Kirsten no Gators for him today it was
very tough to actually make him go out
he's convinced he's going to be savaged
by ticks he's probably correct and he's
being filmed by a David East or the
other David semi-new David's around the
place at the moment my plan was probably
to go down towards Chitra Davin see if
we can't find the Avoca males that were
on there today as explained to me by
David Goethe who has now learned which
dam is which is a good start
I'd say after just a few days here okay
let's have one last look at the birds
the reason I stopped at these birds is
that they tend at this time of the years
we go into the winter to start to flock
for some reason I'm not really sure why
nobody really knows why I don't think
but in the wintertime they tend to flock
much more than they do in the summer
probably because they're not breeding
and so they are not particularly
competitive over mates or territory so I
think that's what's going on them what I
do we're gonna make our gentle way down
towards Chitra down
Sunday afternoon but blustery apparently
around about 27 degrees everything's
quite that hot at 71 or visit 71 that's
what he said 75 or actually Celsius
Fahrenheit rush before I waffle myself
into a hole let's go across to a mr.
Ralph Kirsten on his large engages feast
well thank you James and I tell you what
yeah I'm not going to be getting bitten
by any ticks today welcome aboard
on the afternoon bush walk I say welcome
aboard but we're out on foot and what a
wonderful day it is this afternoon a
little bit blustery as James has said a
little bit earlier but it's quite warm
it's definitely not cold my name is
Ralph Kirsten and on the camera we've
got Davi Howser Davi please don't forget
to join us in the hashtag Safari live on
Twitter and on the youtube live chat
send us your questions and your comments
and get involved on this reality Bush
walk now the first thing I wanted to do
was obviously get up a termite man
because that's the best thing to do when
you're out in the bush get a little bit
of heart scan the area see what's around
get your ears out get your senses
working let your eyes feel for any
movement and the first little bit of
movement that I spotted was one on one
of my favorite trees archaea in the
field and it was actually in this little
hole in there there were a couple of
squirrels that I think have made their
home in here now they were having a
family TIFF and some of them scuttled
off into the grass and I think they
might be one or two of them and down
there at the moment but what a wonderful
tree this is have a look at it
it is so characteristic and this bark of
the lid wood or the cambree tum' in burb
and lid wood being very indicative of
how heavy the woods and dense the wood
is these trees can live for hundreds if
not thousands of years and once they die
they remain as
for pretty much the same as long as as
long as they've lived so hundreds if not
thousands of years so squirrels and
vultures and lizards and all sorts of
animals will use this as their home and
so for me one of the special characters
that we do have our chair it's not all
about the spotted cats and the lions and
the hyenas we've got to look a little
bit closer some of the the big
characters that if they've been through
it all they've seen world wars come and
go they've seen people come and go
they've seen different animals move in
and out and well elephants they're not
gonna be pushing this guy over and so I
think I really like the lead word now I
think we're going to see what small
little things we're going to be finding
today I'll always be happy if I can find
some hyena tracks and we'll try and
follow up and see if we can find that
elusive hyena den but let's see what we
can find in the meantime or just off to
Steve I think it was to say hello good
afternoon everybody
how are we doing this afternoon my name
is Steve Falcon Richard I'm joined on
camera by the impeccable Sebastian and
we are out on Drive and guess what we
are going to go do we are in our way to
attendee was this morning I have not
seen her or Columba in a very long time
so apparently Rob said hyena ralph said
there's a little bit of meat left on the
steer Marcus morning so hopefully when
we get there we're going to see it so
we're very excited please don't forget
to send through your questions hashtag
safari live or follow us on the YouTube
stream either one will do okay
I wasn't expected to see that but this
is clearly where the Avoca males came
through last night let me just move over
and get it just there sybbie okay we
just saw a track just going to jump out
real quick
can you see that okay so we had them
right up in the north last night on the
show right up of buffers look damn they
probably came walking straight down sort
of this Western sort of side and all the
way straight through as I mentioned this
morning when we were looking for all
sorts of tracks just below behind us as
the Milwaukee weird this other tributary
drains it very dry riverbeds at the
moment it's the highway IND room at the
moment all the cats are moving through
so I'm on a better Lee Road I thought
I'd just come up here on our way to
Tandy and I don't think anyone drove
here this morning because they would
have seen these cats but all these
tracks but needless to say they were
farm this morning anyway
and you got to see them which is
marvelous but we are going to continue
I'm sorry for that quick stop beautiful
big male lion track and there's more in
the red yes definitely the three boys
that came down south
mmm Ally very good question the
Birmingham boys seem to be dominating
the entire sabi sands at the moment
without any competition we're right up
in the northern sabi sands and so their
focus seems to be carving up this piece
of territory so I don't think anything
will become of the evoke because if I
mean of the birmingham's if the Evoque
is established yeah that just might sort
of push the birmingham's down a bit
they've got plenty of space to maneuver
in there being a little bit greedy to be
honest they taking up as many lion
prides as they can as much territory as
they can which is unsustainable I mean
if you look at the Roman army back in
the day it eventually it lost because it
was too spread out you know it's very
difficult to defend a frontier that is
enormous that encompasses the entire
Europe and East Asia and North Africa
without some expense so the four males
need to patrol regularly if they can't
patrol they're going to lose out those
territories because territory holders
need to be active in those areas and I
mean we don't see the Birmingham's often
enough for me to think that they could
hold on to this but obviously something
happened in the South the male's moved
out I don't really know the dynamics too
well there's a cuckoo looks like in the
valence cuckoo I think just over my
shoulder here a little bit of a late
bloomer you see the stripes on the chin
on the chest the beautiful crest long
black tail here we go
the valence cuckoo
they like to parasitize on Aramark
babblers I think Aramark bebés just live
here and he's obviously a late fledging
fledgling and I doubt he's gonna
Margaret back north with the rest of the
cuckoos that have already left so he
might be strategy and overwinter and I
wonder if he's gonna enjoy a diet of
something other than caterpillars which
is what the cuckoos enjoy okay well
we're gonna continue on as I said
heading into the area of Tandy from this
morning and in the midst I'll miss go to
mr. James Henry and see how he's doing
oh I'm doing fine I am doing as I was
doing before I saw you lost I'm looking
for animals that is what one does on a
game Drive and enjoying the general
atmosphere of the autumn there is a
there are two interesting birds here the
first one however is the most colorful
and that is the orange breasted bush
Shrike calling from this gardenia bush
over here is now the sister of this
there it is okay since it's gone into
the edge of that completing bush there
you see it there you see it oh no it's
to the right left of that left yeah that
bush right in there the green bush now I
think that's about right where it was
but it's obviously gone now can you see
the Oriole perched upon the tall tree
beyond hope hopeless effort from me now
the Oriole still there it will not fly
away as we focus on it yeah very nice
bright yellow juxtaposed with the bluish
hue behind it and that is the
black-headed Oriole slightly less
fancied cousin and the European golden
Oriole and the most beautiful Oriole
which is the African golden Oriole the
African golden is basically just a
flying blob of gold
James you say that's very beautiful and
obviously that's not me that is somebody
watching the show called James
beautifully named person you are you
said is very beautiful is there
certainly one of my favorites and I
think they would known as lovely call -
they've got a horrible alarm call yeah
they've got this gorgeous liquid kind of
them
sounds like molten liquid being dropped
I'll play it for you feel like those
Rockets ends on and I thought you might
that's why I suggested here we go
beautiful whistling liquid cool and just
now I'm sure it's going to give us the
alarm core which is very unpleasant
this bird is new 60 sir you can see that
trend was beak and he's not a Shrike and
Lily there are probably about a while
till either so we go through the list of
the Sharks together Lily you can then
count them we've got the lesser grace
rank and the red-backed Shrike and the
white crown Shrike and the gray head
Bush right the orange blistered Bush
Shrike the magpie Shrike the red seas
helmet Reich I suppose that could be a
Shrike the white crested helmet right so
that's 8 then we also have the - Chad
gross species they're both Shrike so the
crown chakra and the brown Crown Chakra
that's 10 you're going to have start
using my tone now
um I think we may have run out of Fricks
which is a good thing because I've run
out of fingers
shall we say ten trikes and we'll ask
David to give me the books just so that
I can make sure he seems to be sitting
on my book David this book is very old
okay if it it has survived many many
years and if it doesn't survive this
game drive because you've been sat on it
I shall be deeply upset
let that be a stern warning to you Lily
one second it was one second here we go
okay let's see if I was right great bull
shark we have there you got them their
sins all that so we garden you got one
of those and we got two of the helm
trike so that's two we have the orange
bristled brush Shrike
so that's sorry that's four and they're
the two chakras so that's five and six
then we have all the booboo sharks I
forgot about them southern boo-boo so
that's seven the fiscal we can find that
here sometimes so that's eight the brew
brew I forgot about him - that's nine
the puff pack I forgot about him -
that's ten magpie Shrike we said 11 red
that track 12 white crown Shrike 13
lesser grace Reich
14 14 shrikes Lily that's a lot of
shrikes really isn't it good very nice
question thank you for that
I'm just gonna go and have a little look
around tree house water all because
Steve said he had tracks of a leopard
around there yesterday and so let's go
and find out what Ralph is finding on
his own two feet
well everyone I've just come to this
area it's sort of around the area of
Rebecca's Road Zoe's Road because I've
been intrigued desert this this some
silver Castelli forest here and it's
always nice and cool in this area as
well because of how many trees there are
in this area and I'm pretty sure it's
down to there being a lot of mineral
salts in this particular zone because
they they like to grow a net and the
silver cluster leaf I'm talking about
are these trees here are now there's
been a lot said about them but this
particular area here is where there is a
lot of them and that in fact is like a
forest of sort of cluster leaves and as
I was saying a lot of mineral salts in
the soil and that's normally down to
there being an a/c plan so where the
water is coming out and and dispersing
here in this particular area resulting
in evaporation and leaving behind all
those mineral salts it's a very
impressive and I just thought we'd come
through and have a look um this one in
front of us seems like it's starting to
seed it's got those nice sort of pink
looking seeds on it and a lot of the
locals there actually along with the
purple pod cluster leaf or the low felt
cluster leaf they actually make a very
nice tea out of it now remember the
other day we were watching the Impala
actually feeding on these leaves which
is very strange because it makes your
mouth very dry but like we were I was
saying with Darby when we were up there
I was thinking maybe they're trying to
you know solidify the stomach a little
bit if they've got a bit of a loose
bowel so that's what I was thinking but
I haven't spoken to anybody that knows
any reason why they Impala were doing
that they must know something we don't
but I think that it's definitely down to
something like that now he always comes
through and have a look and just see if
there's any anything interesting about a
particular tree Jason the tallest trees
here in the juma concession itself or in
our Traverse probably things like the
jackal berries some of the niala trees
but I would say jackal berry probably
being you know next to the river on
areas they're probably one of the bigger
ones and that's where we do get a lot of
the biggest trees we do have some last
big marilla's there's there's not too
many paler beds they they seem to be a
bit more north up in the kruger park
itself but um here along this particular
area I would say definitely jackal berry
some niala trees as well and and maybe
some of the marilla's the false
marilla's too and as we go past there
there's another a weeping wattle and do
you know why it's called a weeping
wattle anybody I'd like to know if
anybody knows why it's called a weeping
wattle
there's three trees that we call rain
trees one of them is the African weeping
wattle
another one being the Apple leaf the
Apple leaves with us very big leaves I
will show you one and the other one
being the bulb in the Scotia species and
they've all got particular reasons why
they are called rain trees and this this
weeping water down to a lot of the
flowers and things the drop of the
nectar as well as the Scotia tree also
em when they're flowering extreme nectar
that drops off but there's something
very important about these trees why
they really called the rain tree is
because they get um a spittle bug which
the lava lives on the branch and they
encase themselves with a lot of it's
like spittle they make a foam around
themselves to stop them from drying out
it's not the right time of year for that
but um they make so much of this farm
that dead it drips off of the tree
itself so if you walk underneath you can
feel like it's raining so those three
trees
being the rain trees
stiff good answer there also thank you
for joining us on the under on the walk
and saying that the leaves turned down
when when this rain or rain on the way
and obviously when they do turn down
like that then it also collects a lot of
rain and starts to pour off of those the
leaflets so compound leaves very
interesting the three Rhine trees
remember that is the bulb in the African
weeping wattle and the Apple leaf that's
a very interesting about those three
trees so we're on the road yeah that
we're just jumping onto now we're gonna
see if we can pick up on any hyena
tracks and what else is around okay
while we hit off and try and get some
checks I'm also gonna get back into this
silver cluster leaf forest it seems
James got a very big animal to show you
off to him well here is a small herd of
elephants just three of them so you can
see probably count to three unusually
sort of small herd and unusually led by
a youngish cow I find it always very
interesting when there's a small herd
like this to figure out why why there
are so few of them this is this is magic
people that have them disclose to us is
absolute magic and not reacting in a
negative way at all be very kind about
being with us thank you don't don't do
anything silly there you'll just stay
right where you are lovely elephant
you're taking legal photograph of you
throwing sound on coming right past oh
she's got a nasty gash in her tusks
there
isn't that fantastic
this is just brilliant
so I wouldn't say she's much more than
maybe 20 years old and I think she's
pregnant again Jamie you say this is
amazing it is and you know some of the
most profound experiences I've ever had
out here have been with elephants like
that she's just watching us till now
she's just giving a little bit of a head
shakes are not gonna move it's just kind
of saying stay where you are let me get
away a bit protecting her to come I
can't both be her calves I don't think
the smaller one differently is now
suddenly she's reacting in a manner that
is there any unpleasant
well not unpleasant she just lifted her
head and she's showing alarmed I will
try and show to you and I wonder if it
isn't because the wind may be switched
and she got wouldn't of smell of us but
the wind is coming from the southeast so
it's coming from behind her and think
that's the reason I think it was because
she saw sins or shirt and she actually
wanted it Alicia the only thing that
triggered that reaction from that
elephant is the same thing that triggers
aggression in any other animal and
that's fear there is almost nothing else
that will trigger an aggressive response
from an animal other than fear and so
she is feeling threatened by us she's
feeling that maybe her little calf is
threatened by our presence and so she
reacted by doing that David why are you
trying to contort yourself into a small
Kathy you're wondering if this is a cow
and two kids I'm looking at them
thinking that the older youngster you
know what I mean is possibly a little
bit too old to be her calf you see I'd
put that one at about ten if she's 20
it's possible she might be a bit more
than 20 what's quite telling those that
the older calf has got very similarly
shaped tusks to this young matriarch and
I wonder if that doesn't say something
have asked a genetic connection between
them so it's quite possible that they're
both her calves the tusks of the younger
one did straight like that cars got a
bit of a wound on her backside you see
about the tail there she's also got the
same kind of thing behind her ears
that's either a skin disease or she's
been spiked in the bun by I can only
think of tusks
I'm always fascinated by a small herds
like this because I don't really
understand how they form she would have
left a much bigger herd or maybe her
herd has kind of died around her you
know she ended up as the oldest female
in a small herd as the rest of the older
females stopped giving birth and died
off now you saw her moving her trunk
around there extending it towards us and
in fact all three of them did that yes
Becca
they are absolutely trying to smell you
when they're doing that that is the
beginning of the nose for them she's
gonna give them a little bit of distance
I don't want to give them a big fright
so nice to spend a bit of time with
elephants I'm looking at her now
thinking she's not maybe as young as I
thought she was I think she's probably
about 25 so that other one almost
certainly her calf as well
now I think that the older calf is a
female I'm not sure about that younger
one and Alicia the older one if she is a
female which I think she is will stay
with her mother probably for most of her
mother's life and if the younger one is
a little bull he will move away
eventually as he gets older but he'll
stay within this herd and with his
sibling until he's probably about 14 or
15
and I'm going to see if I can get into a
different position and Steve ovo has had
some success
yes we have and we have found Tandy and
she is back up in the tree with
apparently a Steinbach kill I can't
really see too much of it but there is
no sign of Columba I think she's going
to make me wait a little bit longer
before revealing herself the little
bundle of joy
was her old name now she's officially
been named Columba the playful one and
tummy is very relaxed
you might hear the sound of a vehicle we
have just been joined by one of the
landowners from bull silk the typical
leopard pose isn't that marvelous so I'm
gonna put a little quiz out there to all
of you wonderful viewers now you know I
enjoy my trees so I wonder who can tell
me what tree sandy is in one if you
could tell me what tree she is in at the
moment with her carcass hashtag Safari
live and she's being shy she's not
showing her face at the moment
hmm I'm super-stoked sabbath's taped as
well we haven't seen her I can't
remember the last time I saw her I have
seen her since I'm here back from Kenya
but I haven't seen Columbo yet only on
the screen but that's not the same thing
I need to see her jumping around in the
grass and apparently Ralph said she kept
bringing the carcass down the tree for
the lumber to feed on and then hyenas
would come and then she would take it
back up and then she'd take it down and
it back up and down because Colombo was
finding it difficult to eat it while
suspended in the tree Rafael knows not a
tamarind tree I don't think we get
tamarind trees here and it's not a
leopard tree either folks if you're
going to guess that there's a very
common tree if you've been watching my
drops you'll know we have spoken about
it on many occasion there's the leaves
mmm Linda you are correct but I'm going
to let a few more viewers get the
answers in Lin is hundred percent
correct with her answer it's a tree that
we find so many times with animals
shading underneath Allen node is not a
marula tree very fine leaves very very
very fine leaves lots and lots of shade
we've had the young Tambor up at with
his crew kill his Kuruvita skills should
I say we've had Hosanna many times
underneath eminent in them I've had that
one Kahuna pride with the kudu kill
underneath one see those pods
mmm Dale and Paula does not indication
it has no thorns but it does look like
an acacia limb so FAR's got a correct
isn't that just the most marvelous light
we just need tündi to turn her face a
little bit towards us so he can get so
you can get some marvelous screen shots
Molly it is indeed the toilet-paper bush
the poor man's toilet paper bear in mind
not the rich man's toilet paper Somalian
and well done the toilet paper tree the
African weeping wattle and is a very
important tree our cheerful for shade it
is browsed upon the pods will give you a
bad tummy if you eat them and the shade
element that it brings them and just in
the time I've been here since January
how many times have I seen not only a
leopard in them with the kill but
shading underneath them as well as lions
a very very important tree definitely
given me a new outlook on on these trees
and I'll never look at them the same
whenever I see when I'm always looking
for the elusive spotted cat is perched
in the branches
Oscar yes Tandy knows me I'm the newest
member of the team but I spent a lot of
time with her in January
especially when them Palumbo was very
young it was about three months or so
we're very very close to to camp we got
to see two three minutes out of camp she
was there to see almost every day so
very very spoiled I just got a whiff of
the stand Bach the window just changed
smells lovely
so Tandy is a very relaxed kept every
now and again she can be quite Moody
but I mean that's just part of her
personality we've had some wonderful
sightings with her I'm hoping in the
next little while I'm sure she's gonna
make us earn her a little humble will
come out of the woodwork in proper
proper form because the way she's
positioned with this afternoon light if
the lumber goes up that tree it's going
to be gorgeous
Aidan seven years old she climbs up this
she's got a very very sharp claws and if
she is a cat she's just a very big one
and they are very very good at climbing
trees and that's not even a difficult
tree to climb I've seen leopards go
straight after probably vertically about
20 feet just straight up but before
getting to the branch and I've seen them
do that with a fully grown female in
parla in their mouth so pound for pound
the strongest cat very sharp claws
designed for grabbing onto branches
pulling themselves up and also designed
for pulling down prey much bigger than
themselves
undressed no I don't say I ever feel at
risk but every now and again you do get
this feeling in the tummy like one time
we had Tandy we were parked pretty much
as we are
Tandy walked behind our car and hoisted
a water warthog up a tree and then
because we don't have any doors in the
car here and then salamba tried to
follow her and then they kind of got we
got between her and Tandy and she tried
to walk around the car and I remember
turning my head and looking at Tammy and
she was about a metre from my foot she
was looking at me with a very unhappy
look on her face but we hadn't done
anything wrong cabin hood just kind of
walked around our car and gotten a
little bit separated and then she looked
at me as if I was to blame but it is
indeed has made my heart race a little
bit these are still wild cats I mean we
assume that they're never going to jump
on the car that is the behavior that
they have exhibited for many many years
but there's nothing really to stop them
from doing so apart from the fact that
don't see us as food so as long as we
can maintain net discipline in that
balance we are perfectly safe on the car
Marcy I am looking everywhere but I
can't see Columba I'm sure she's just
having she's lying flat somewhere here I
mean there's lots of grass everywhere
lots of bushes one thing I do remember
we were in this area was actually with
yusup the last time I saw tree lumber we
were just up the road here and Tandy had
a kill
she had a warthog and a know a daycare
and a water bucket she was just up the
road up a marula tree and I mean she was
about 70 meters away from Columbia who
was two months younger than she is now
and she was just sort of on their own
mission and a mum would look at to that
at all hmm that little call and
eventually she came back but um so I
don't think she's too bothered by her
lipids are very very independent little
animals and she's probably missing
around looking for some Franklin or
chasing ants or grasshoppers or
something something that young leopards
do but I wouldn't worry but I'm sure
she's here somewhere
hmm Aaron favorite tree species to see a
lipid well that's quite hard you know
Aaron to see it a leopard in a tree and
it's all about them like for example
these trees these African weeping what
was often very very bushy but the way
she's positioned now makes it a perfect
tree but if she was on the other side
that would be a very bad tree my rule is
often very very good led woods are very
very good and in my pastime up in sort
of the middle of Kruger we saw a lipid
in a dead led wood and that was probably
the most spectacular thing not a leaf or
small branch on the tree whatsoever and
a leopard just sort of lying there in
this grey sort of crocodile skin bark
with a very blue background so I've
probably said dead Libra tree is my
favorite to see them in but just seeing
a leopard in the tree for me it's very
special it's a very popular and common
sort of part of the sabi sands if you
want to see a leopard this is the place
to come and you can almost pick the tree
you want to find them in I've seen them
in so many different trees
well we are going to stay here in hopes
of Columba materializing and tündi maybe
getting up and showing us some activity
while we do that let's go to someone
who's walking vigorously in the bush
Ralph Kristin Wow everyone we're still
on the lookout for anything special and
it's a little bit quiet still in that
just often that day you know sometimes
it can be a little bit quiet and when
it's quite warm out in the bush but I'd
like to ask you what would you guys like
me to look for while we're out here on
the bush walk this afternoon you know
I've spent so many years Archy on the
bush and Sam Darvey is just trying to
negotiate his way down there to Martin
and don't fall Darvey and I've spent so
many years out in the bush that
sometimes you you all must take a lot of
things for granted so and also you know
we feel sometimes that we repeat
ourselves on many different topics so
I'd like you to throw some topics to me
or things that you'd like reminding on
things that you'd like new information
on whatever you like and just as we're
walking here you know one of the biggest
things as we're walking through the bush
it all just looks like grass doesn't it
but we've got if we can just stop right
here we've got a lot of different
species of grass here this one is the
little blue grass that I've spoken about
before I mean the little blue wax bull
uses that as nesting material yeah
there's little seeds give a little blue
tinge to it that's why it's called that
not not not a very Impella table grass
but still a grass all the same now
Alicia I'm going to try and find you
lots of cool little insects I will do
that another one here that we have this
is called finger grass for obvious
reason you see what it looks like they
up like the fingers pointing up okay
so nice and easy that one also not a
very palatable grass
so once again we're getting an
indication that this is not particularly
a palatable area for animals and this
one being the hay
in grass looking very much like on the
cartoons when when a little cat it's a
fish and it pulls the burn out pretty
much full netted and clean so that's why
it's called a hearing burn grass also
not very palatable and then the nasty
buggers that we don't like which also is
one of the reasons why we wear Gators
apart from them the ticks are these guys
here this is Aristotle and jester or the
tehsil 3 or nuts waving around a bit
castle 3 or and it's called that because
of these little seeds that they have
they they have three little ons on them
you see there 1 2 3 as I turn it
sideways but it's like a little spear
that goes into your socks and very
irritating and it look at the gracia it
is completely full of this stuff so when
you walk through here these tassel 3
owns really get into your socks and
really irritate you so wearing gaiters
is one of the things it really helps
fighting instead among apart from the
ticks that's one of the reasons why we
use that and there's my guy says yes you
can see these tests all three ons just
sticking into my shoes as well lots of
them they're starting to irritate me
already and part of my shoes and very
well protected but that's what we do so
and this Darvey he's got hardcore canvas
ones rogue he is a road man yes okay and
I hear that somebody's also looking for
an art for call that's something that
I'm going to look for so two things I'm
going to be looking for interesting
insects and an article I think that's
that's fantastic so let's do that Davi
that's the mission
now Beth there's a couple of there's a
couple of plants that are exotic and
considered nuisances one of them being
the blackjack which I think came over
from Europe in with the horses and a
blackjack in in Afrikaans we call it
very descriptive come up to Cairo which
is the black seeds quite similar to the
Aristotle congesting the irritability
that they give you but very straight
seed black and they literally stick on
all your clothes they stick on all your
socks and you've got to pluck them out
like quite a lot and it's all these
irritating plants like that there are
pioneers but normally also alien so
brought across from from other countries
that really become a problem and they
seeds are spread so easily because then
only get stuck on the wool of the
animals United in this in in the
southeast in the Eastern Cape of South
Africa where I'm from we get this it's
it's a jointed cactus so it's a cactus
that goes very close to the ground very
close to the ground look at but it's got
a lot of thorns on it and as the animals
walk past those thorns go into the legs
and you almost don't feel it and but
their legs can be full of this stuff and
then obviously they bite it and pull it
out and but they spread that so much
that it's really really bad stuff and
another one being the Queen of the Night
which is also a cactus like plant and
very tall cactus plants that you would
think it would come from Mexico as
things they might even come from Mexico
and and they they flower at night so
that's why it's called queen of the not
very good for ornamental plants and
that's why they were brought over but
they also encroach into areas quite
prolifically another one being the
prickly pear very very bad the elephants
love to eat it and all of those cactus
like plants as soon as you break a piece
off of it it falls on the ground it can
grow another one from there so people
think that elephants are eating those
prickly pears and decimating them it's
far from the truth that prickly pear
will go
through in their dung and wherever
they've broken a piece down on the
ground it will grow all over the place
so it literally it spreads like wildfire
it's terrible stuff really really
terrible stuff so there are quite a few
exotic plants another one here that we
get is a wild tobacco which we generally
find in the riverbeds and it makes quite
a pretty flower as well not good for
smoking at all I don't know why they
call it a while to Becca I think it's
just in the same family okay I'm off to
try and find some art Fork and
interesting insects and while we do that
let's head you back to Steve was tandy
Hobie marvelous you could find an
aardvark in the day I've never seen that
before ruff good luck and you can see
the claws that she uses to climb up the
tree they are what we call in lions and
leopards we call protract tile floors
some people mistake them for retractable
claws they're not a retractable they're
able to be extended which means they're
protract art and then they go back in as
as normal position so by extending their
their wrists they actually extend the
claws art and then when they relax they
come back in again
so not retractable protractor and then
you can see she's revealing one of them
for us now sorry glue only got the last
bit of your question there
Ravinder no she's still got some up
there I can't see much of it I wonder if
you can see the leg behind her back leg
there again if you just punch in there
there you can still see the leg of the
Steinbach up there we go
so there is still some up there but we
haven't seen too much of it there's not
too much apparently Ralph we left this
morning there was still quite back
behind hindquarters of the steamboat
crystal visible and for her store to be
up the tree kind of defending it means
is still enough meat to see her through
another little while
croutha Tandy's about 12 years old I
believe somewhere in that range she's
been around for a long time and she has
been the mother to many cups so she is
then we'd call the new queen of jummah
after Corolla past who was her mother I
believe a Murat sip yeah yes
so shadow and tend Tandy shadow hasn't
been seen at some time there were
sisters and shadow hasn't been that
apparent hasn't been the best mom I
don't know how many of her Cubs have
survived but Tandy's done very very well
very very well over the years but as
Tristan has told me Tristan is up in the
Mara and I said that Tennys getting to
the stage where she's gonna stop reading
and this might even be her last litter
so this last legacy of hers calamba
which is awesome because it is a young
lady and the young ladies are destined
to stay within the area and it means you
be able to document and follow this
youngster and as it comes of age and
sort of moves into the space of her
mother the queen of jummah
okay well we've got one of the big five
that I'm not doing too much let's go
over to someone who's got a big animal
of the big five I think we're live hang
on a second okay are we live
we've just gone live okay good I will
carry on with our elephants you please
as you were squeeze past but I will mean
sorry about that everybody I was beating
some friends I do have some there they
are I do apologize for that the
elephants are just gone into raw the
large thick it over here and oh no no
that's not your fault Luke's just saying
sorry it's my fault entirely
let's get one last view of them I've
been sitting here trying to do what we
call an end board for school Drive and
it basically means I just have to
deliver two lines or so to the camera
with the elephants in the background you
can't believe I talk for a living cannot
believe how long it takes me to learn
two lines of script there we go I'll
matriarch friend
there was talk of there being rain today
slightly strange withered afternoon I
don't think it's particularly wet I
don't think it's going to get wet but
there's definitely a front coming
through and I suspect tomorrow morning
will be quite chilly now I made the
assertion that I thought this cows about
25 years old
I thought the youngster was probably
that youngster didn't actually give an
estimate of I think probably about four
and probably wondering how I managed to
do that well what you do Paula is you
count the veins on the back of the ear
and that gives you an idea since oh I
can't believe you actually believe me as
well I'm talking rubbish
it's it's just through guessing Paula
it's through guessing and experience so
I've learned from people who'd be not
here for much longer than I had and I'd
say how old is that elephant how's that
elephant in there tell me and basically
that's how I guess and so it's very
inaccurate I mean it could be entirely
inaccurate i I don't think she's older
than 25 she could be thirty but I think
it's very unlikely and basically it's
from size skin condition the shape of
the back and the head they get much more
angular as they get older and they also
tend not to stop growing I mean they
will slow down going towards the end but
they do get taller and bigger for their
whole lives you can see an old elephant
an old elephant looks like an old human
being there's that little wound that I
told you about earlier now I think
that's a spike from a tusk I think
something's had a goad her there
marvelous to have some elephants again
sometimes in a situation like this Paula
when there are three elephants I mean if
some fate was to puff before the two
calves here she might live a solitary
life but most likely what will happen is
that you would join another herd when
they get very old however then they do
tend to leave the herd and go off
towards softer foods on the rivers where
they eventually die but that's the only
kind of real reason a female would
choose to live on her own it would be
very unusual for a female and good
health to decide to live entirely on her
own
oh look there we go he's just trying to
test his strength now I know that my
parents and certainly many of you on a
Sunday afternoon would have had a
substantial nap of the elephant's Panza
is that the name Panza the elephant's
tend not to have an enormous sleep
during the afternoon and in fact Pan
Jack sorry they sleep very little and
the it seems to be that the bigger a
mammal is the less it will sleep and so
I don't think that they sleep often for
more than 2 or 3 or 4 hours a day and
when they're smaller they sleep for much
longer than that so no I don't think
they would have they would doze much
during the day I have seen big Bulls
sitting on very hot days I'll stand in
the shade and they're just sort of you
can see they're just not with it they're
flapping their wings their wings their
ears and then they're just kind of fast
asleep so that's what they do but they
don't sleep fully during the day and in
fact a big bull elephant will sleep very
little compared to the human being all
right they've gone off into the thickets
I think we're going to press on see what
else we can find you might see if we can
head towards there's big male lions at
chitwa chitwa ha
till one gear ha
I believe Steve has done very
interesting things he has changed
position
yes well sandy got up and moved and
she's now hugging her little caucus and
for the sensitive viewers you might not
want to look at this now but to look
away if you need to but here is the
steam box face which has been badly
badly munched on by Tandy such an evil
looking look on it now there's obviously
very dead
but it's a prize
for a little female Steinbach has fallen
victim to the claws of this very good
and professional hunter
she's repositioned is having a nice sort
of sits down in the tree she's looking a
little bit more comfortable than she was
good better water Queen had what a queen
Alexandr fibers old no leopards I don't
believe get more spots they just grow
into the spots more and the spots get
began spread out as you have we see
Columba you'll see how many spots she's
got and those spots just like the fur in
the body that everything just expands
and stretches there very spotty at birth
and if anything they get more golden in
between the spots they're quite dark
when they're younger I think it aids in
camouflage and also keeping them a
little bit warmer because darker fur is
is more insulating than lighter fare
what is she spotted
as she calling me I wonder if she was
looking to call pink Columbo moved off
sort of northeast from where we are now
she's not looking in that journal
direction but it's a good chance that
she's circled around this maybe coming
back
definitely interested in something but
there was also hyenas this morning sandy
might've spotted hyena she might have
even spotted another animal tooth to
prey on such as the daycare another
Steinbach more than Paula who knows
she's definitely showing some sort of
interest there Pam Jackie leopards can
hunt daily they don't need to but I mean
they can hunter twice in a day three
times is that all depends on on the
conditions with the animals that they
are hunting I've seen a leopard up a
tree with the baby zebra and to warthogs
and we saw it catch that zebra in the
morning and then successfully we didn't
see it catch the warthogs but they were
they up in the tree with the zebra from
the morning so and then there can also
go days without hunting so condition
plays a big part not just the condition
of the leopard but condition of the prey
animals as winter gets more and more dry
and more and more harsh your prey
animals are weaker and much easier to
catch but then at the same time the
cover is blown a little bit for the
leopards and they have to work a little
bit harder to hunt oh that was a
beautiful yarn so there's nothing to
stop her from hunting with a kill I mean
for example I'm really surprised that
she's still got well she still got meat
yeah because she knows she's eating
again now because a Steinbach is not a
huge animal and she's been with it for
what two days or something there we go
she's calling so I think she was already
full when she caught this there she's
busy calling her cub it's listen sorry
you might hear a vehicle they're getting
a little bit stuck over there it's very
sandy
they just need to engage they're low low
range she's coming down the tree should
I move forward Sybil you want me to stay
there what's there right there
I'm just going to move
see how she disappears in the long grass
they're very difficult to spot the spots
so you're being very opportunistic
hunters they will hunt as many times
they need to and if something just comes
around while they're in a tree with a
kill in a fool there's nothing to stop
them going down and stalking and hunting
again listen she's calling
no Lily there's not too much left there
still a little bit she's not giving it
up yet she is calling her daughter to
come and eat the daughter she should not
leave the table without finishing her
meal
here she comes hip yeah as she comes
just in the long grass yet between the
bush there we go
you got it yes Columba hello my gorgeous
now I don't know how I spotted her there
I think I felt her looking at me if
she's running she's gonna do a loop
around she's gonna come back to mum her
mom is gonna give her a little cuddle
and say where you've been you naughty
girl she's gonna come through the
vegetation there let's see if you can
spot her coming folks this is going to
be a bit of a show because she is
extremely camouflaged
Tandy's in the same place Columba's
directly in front of us now there she is
there she is
well done said she's coming all the way
around mum is calling with the steam
rock in her mouth sorry if my head gets
in the way I'm so excited
Sandy's in the same place she's just
here
good girl sandy yeah she comes there she
is there and she is I'm just going to
move forward because Charlie's gonna get
her in the open here
she's gonna come out issue
don't go in there Tandy that's very
thick bush your little Cubs about to
sneak up behind you there she comes
there she goes yes give me my meat mum
that's what she's just said giraffe go
my heart is bursting with happiness as
well I'm so happy to see you this cub
alive there was some dart for some time
and we weren't able to see her but then
being out here in the sort of area it's
very hard to find it not yet
look at this vegetation they're right
there they're right there and unless him
zooms in you can't see it now the Cubs
in the long grass feeding on that that's
team buck and you can't even see her
there she is sorry about my brakes hello
gorgeous mama this is the best thing
ever
if she has grown so much she is so
cheeky she's been off gallivanting and
she's still a little she's still little
I was thinking after two months she
would have grown more but I mean I went
to see her in the open but she's still
very little there's definitely becoming
a little Lepidus just going to get
Aubree one of their game viewers he's
just coming in to join us
whoops you can just come around the side
eh okay well it looks like Ralph is
found and we're looking to make a
promise to all of you let's go see what
he's found then I have indeed everybody
here we are next to a termite mound but
a termite mound that's got quite a big
cavity in it over there now there is
nobody else and that could make a cavity
like that other than an art fog so
whoever was looking for an artwork
burrow here is one and well let's have a
look inside there it it is quite deep
that goes in for at least a meter and a
meter and a half as I put the light on
it and then it goes up and around the
corner now the reason behind that is you
want you have that little Baldy at the
bottom so that it goes up so when it
rains the water will obviously sit in
that little bowl and you can then get up
and be high and dry and that's what the
art fork has done and afterwards
warthogs can also use this Barrow and
they do something similar as well
they'll also make a little Leeds like
that so especially the piglets can go
and set up on on that little ledge
because they don't have as much meat on
him as mummy does and they need to sit
up nice and warm
out of the water sometimes mommy will
sit in that bowl and she was in but
she's got enough meat on her to stay
even when she's wait but the little
piglets up are on the dry stuff and
there's a lot of animals that will use
odd for burrows so they are the unsung
heroes of the bush because not only
warthogs will use them
jackals will use them to Danan we've
seen that many times before
hyenas we've seen that here on Juma
plenty as well lipids will put their
cubs in these are 12 burrows - I'm sure
lots of you have seen that even lions
will do that as well honey badgers
cannot think of any other mammals if we
go on to reptiles we talk about the
monitor lizards they can use that as
their home black numbers and other
different snakes will also use that to
hibernate in and then we also talked
about birds there's a couple of birds
that will use this as a nesting site one
being the blue swallow and another one
being the South African shell duck so
there is a number of animals that really
rely on our Fox and you know what this
some that even don't exist where you
don't get art form now Paula this this
kind of hole here is generally the size
of of an odd for para but the question
remains how big does it get on the
inside well it it all depends on how
many the the little odd fork has in his
family or if he's making it as a den
site mostly they dig just an evening
shelter that they'll go in overnight and
then they'll move on but when they make
themselves an actual den site it can be
rather large on the inside so they are
fascinating and I tell you what you
don't get many warthog where you don't
get art for because they're all almost
solely reliant on an odd fork for their
burrows yes they will excavate a little
bit more around it and on the inside
that they cannot dig that with this nut
which is what they use to excavate so
just imagine trying to excavate this
massive hole yer entirely which is not
now
Kathy I've seen quite a number of art
walk in my life mostly at night okay and
and being quite lucky here in the Kruger
Park but I haven't seen most of them
here in this area that we're in right
now I've seen one or two at night and
but in the Eastern Cape where I am from
it is quite unusual there we see a lot
of art Fox and one of my friends and a
mentor for me as well they all held mice
that I used to work with try and say
that one shall denies and a very good
friend of mine and he's more experienced
than me he had been working in the bush
for almost 20 years and he had never
seen an artifact he'd seen the checks
and and I we used to laugh at him
because we often had the checks going
past his tent in the morning and he's
deceived al didn't you see that one but
now so they're very secretive very
difficult to see but they leave the
signs all over the place and such
wonderful burrow diggers they're very
important for the ecosystem Atiyah now
there is one little thing I do want to
show you just before you go off to all
the other exciting things and this is
just one of the things that is so
impressive in the bush when a little
bird finds a Buffaloes form which is
full of thorns there and he makes his
little nest up in there now I'm sure
this is something like a terrestrial
brown ball or something along those
lines because it's a very sticky nest
but I can't I'm not gonna attempt to
climb in the tree because I think I
might disturb it but I'm pretty sure
there's a cup or a bowl on the inside so
it looks a little bit haphazard on the
outside but I think on the inside there
it is quite ball shaped and quite
organized and maybe here's even some
spider web to make it soft on the inside
there and that's something looking like
a little terrestrial brown ball but what
a clever way to defend your nest nice
inside a buffalo thorn tree
it's just absolutely fascinating how
nature works huh so we go from one
amazing thing the art Foxboro and we've
spotted now little I think the
terrestrial bramble mist in this bath
zone that is absolutely fantastic now
for folder one promise we need to start
looking for some special insects country
Columbus come out and attendees provided
here with the remainder of that
Steinbach but now they are both Tandy's
life let when Columbus in there
somewhere he is busy feeding on the
remains of the Steinbach not sure if you
can hear it but it's just this little
sounder she's munching on the bone or
the skin
Tandi was so accommodating bringing it
down for her to sing come on child it's
time to eat most parents will understand
that the kids are too busy having fun to
remember to eat hmm
child of the universe most cats have the
projectile claws cheetah dead claws
don't go back because they are not true
cats they stay after very much like a
dog
same as hyena and that is to give them
grip just like we when we're studs in
our shoes for running gives them grip
for speed and running along the ground
whereas cats like leopard lion house
cats wild cats
Genet's and they all have very sharp
protract our claws which enables them to
climb trees and also potentially to
catch their prey which they then grab
onto both feet front and back the
leopard and the domestic cat have that
very good ability to grab something with
the front paws and then sort of
eviscerate the stomach with with their
back feet which is always quite fun my
cat used to do it to me all the time
when it's only kind of lost its mind and
suddenly attack in my hand and then
clawed it all over the place and that is
purely a function of ability to help
them climb they call a climb and I'm not
easy for them to get away and leopard
needs to be able to take its food up the
tree we've seen cheetah and lose their
prey many many many times many times
because they've don't take their prey up
the tree and leopards are able to then
feed on their prey for days and days and
days
just have another vehicle coming in to
join us Texan from Rio Taylor the
vegetation is a very thicker aren't yet
you have to be very careful because as
Ralph is talking about the odd vaak
Burris there's lots and lots of odd pock
burrows all around Tess her
repositioning might be quite tricky but
while we stay here and hope the little
the youngster comes out on the scope
James and see what he's up to
well we are approaching the site of the
Avoca males I believe that they are
flatter than the proverbial pancake in
other words they are very
enthusiastically performing the way that
Lions do best
but nevertheless we shall assist them
and perhaps we shall even be able to
give them some kind of characterization
I don't think we've quite got a handle
on who's who is amongst the coalition I
just need to find out the correct road
I'm not very good with my roads on [ __ ]
at the moment
they're on a road called Mike's kitchen
that is quite interesting
let's hope I can find mike's kitchen
I think it's down this way I hope it's
down this way my only doubt is that
there are hundreds of general game
individuals around here there are water
back in y'all own parlor fact masses are
in parlor all the best
it's not looking very hopeful at this
stage
you might have to consult my map
actually let me open this up right Maps
I also think I'm getting a flat tire
it's really not good I see this
particular map doesn't have any road
names on it so that's not very good
I would have thought it was down here I
might be wrong
there are masses of general game
[Music]
I think I would have thought that was
Mike's kitchen over there let's just
stop here for a second there are some
animals and you can see we just passed a
little sort of Bush dinner site and I
think that is Mike's kitchen as far as I
understand it this is a classic sabi
sand picture the bull veld Beast
hopefully waiting for females to come
and see him and making sure that he's
safe by lurking around with a herd of
Impala and he's just scraping his peddle
glands on the ground there to make sure
that any other bull ville de beers that
comes past here knows that he is in
charge of this territory devoid as it is
of females now what you see in the
background there are the most common
antelope that we get here of course
those are the Impala and they are
cheetah cat
the ecological equivalent of Springbok
in this area we do not see any Springbok
in the kruger park area in fact they
only occur where the rainfall is
probably about 400 millimetres and below
so there are a truly deserts adapted
species which the Impala are inescapably
not and so for those of you don't know a
springbok is basically the it was the
only southern african gazelle that we
get and it is our national animal but
you don't get any of them over here well
let's keep moving and see if we can't
find where these lions are
nasty feeling I may have the road wrong
but you know figure it out eventually
I'm sure I hope
nice place to have supper especially
when there's nearing full moon as it is
now
one second windows reverse here
alright let me try and figure out where
Mike's kitchen is exactly in the
meantime let's see if Ralph can find any
other kind of kitchen where he is an
unfortunate we've just been looking for
all these little insects but I can I can
tell you at this time of year things
start to get a little bit quiet on the
insect front in this part of the world
because a lot of these insects that we
have here or some are active so are the
dung beetles like some of a lot of the
spiders and the centipedes millipedes we
don't really see them in winter so it's
actually quite tough to find insects as
we head into autumn and going into
winter it's quite difficult we don't see
any more of the the dung beetle beetles
at all they're already gone oh yeah
they're actually you know it's it's a
you know we could - since since we've
seen any at all but here comes some
elephant dung up front yeah and that's
normally a hot spot for little for
little insects and critters on the
inside so let's have a look I don't want
to disturb in too much because you know
there's also their little home so if we
just lift it up we can place it straight
back underneath afterwards there's a
little ants nest and these look like
they could be harvest the ends nice and
closely in there they're still
reasonably fresh elephant dung as well
it's not it's not terribly old it's not
terribly fresh but it's not terribly old
should I said it is still bit moist and
but also when you when you lift up
something like this you also want to be
a little bit careful because you you are
messing with quite a few insects and
things home so what ideas are normally
just put it up on its side have a look
and then you can just try and place it
back exactly where you found it um but
we do want to have a look and see what
is happening around
and you see all of these little ends
what they're doing is they're also
taking little grass clippings down but
they're not feeding on it as the
termites would do their elbow able to
digest cellulose a little bit better
than in the the termites so they're not
using those fungus gardens and these
ants can also be forming a big part of
the an art Fox diet come wintertime so
in summer they feed predominantly on
termites but in winter they can start to
go a lot more onto these little ends
just close up there and it's lift this
one up and see if there's anything else
running around but as I say you see it's
very oh there's more ants
okay so that's another little empty nest
but there's not a lot of other things
around Gary I haven't particularly found
any fossils in the bush we have seen
some that have been fossilized into
rocks in Namibia little snails and fish
and so on but what we do find quite a
lot around these areas here or the old
human habitation where the people has
made stone tools and also pottery
there's a lot of that around the Kruger
National Park area especially up the
northern part in the Macaulay key so
that's mostly what we found a lot of ant
activity and these elephant dongs and
normally if this was in full summer or
spring time a lot of this down would
have been worked by the dung beetles so
at the moment now it's actually just
going down more so to the little ends
and the harvester ants so hey do
continue through the winter a little bit
but they find places like under an
awesome elephant dung and so they do
assist a little bit in in the
decomposition of this
of this energy that is now being placed
Jana also used it as a very good nesting
site so we're still on the hunt for some
interesting insects but they're all
interesting in their own right even
though the quite common is harvester
ants they still fulfilling a very
important role magic dragon wizard I'm
going to find your plant that acts as an
antiseptic this one over here is not one
of those that acts as an antiseptic
however very easy to identify and when I
used to teach my students as soon as you
see this you've got three main veins
coming from the base you see that one
two three and we say black monkey orange
there's a black monkey orange nice
simple leaf with three main veins coming
from the base black monkey orange you
see nice straight branches these trees
are the ones that um they produce a very
nice round fruit very hard outer casing
and they very often hollow them out and
then they can be used as souvenirs or
salt and pepper potts it's a very nice
black monkey orange and the one that I'm
looking for is actually the sickle Bush
the sickle Bush is the pharmacy of the
bush and when I find one I'm going to
show you I'm not seeing any around here
that is an acacia because it's got
thorns on it not spines and we're
looking for the one that looks similar
and the sickle Bush but it doesn't have
thorns it has spines now what is the
difference well a thorn is a modified
leaf and a spine is a matter for a
modified branch so a thorn grows next to
an auxilary but where is a spine grows
from an auxilary bud I'm getting very
technical now let's just look for that
sickle Bush which I'm not seeing for the
minute
okay while I look for my sickle Bush and
I'm sure I'm gonna find one just up
ahead yeah it's hid John over to James
with those wonderful cats well they
might be wonderful when they're sitting
up doing something useful but this thing
barely opened its eyes as we drove in
it's one of the Avoca males I'm told the
other two are here I can see one but I
cannot see the third okay we have Lions
it's good it's getting cooler sun's
starting to set possibly good for us to
settle in for the long haul if not too
many people want to come in here and
just as you look at that flat cat there
at least you can see the vegetation
which tends not to run away or go to
sleep but it is starting to turn can you
see that we're getting the autumnal
colors here and we don't get great
sprays of Burgundy's and pinks and
things that you do in in northern
reaches of the world it just kind of
goes yellow and then leaves fall off and
people you say oMG James found them well
I don't know to be whether to be
insulted or were pleased by that comment
Oh Puma I didn't actually find him
somebody told me where they were and I
had quite a lot of help from David who
was here this morning thank you David
but they're having a very nice long
Sunday siesta
and in fact one would M one would
question whether they were in fact still
extant
if one didn't know that they will lie
wouldn't you I'm not sure that we'll
spend too long here I think we'll
probably go back towards the waterhole
see if Hassan doesn't pop his head out
apparently he was around here earlier
today but Hassan are on the hunt will be
inescapably more entertaining than this
lot now I thought yesterday when I was
on my walk that the roaring sound of
lions in the distance was these guys
calling Joyce and that would have
signified of course that they were
solidifying their domain but I was then
told subsequently that it wasn't them
because I think Steve was quite close to
them if not actually with him when I
heard that roar so I don't know for sure
I think somebody's told me there he's
heard them roaring in fact we have
definitely heard them roaring yeah we
know we they have roared and I think
there's probably been very little
response and so here they remained very
comfortable I think the next step I
think that they are going to be here to
stay I can't see any reason for them not
to stay around
if the Birmingham's don't come back up
north and I can't see any reason why the
Birmingham's would come back up north
and so let us assume that these fat
fellows take over here I'm not sure
what's going to happen with the young
members of the incomers as I said
yesterday during our character catch-up
show it's I think the youngest cub is
old the youngest cub the youngest cub
must be just under a year old a thought
and then the rest of them are almost two
now I think they'll be okay but the
youngest cub could still be in trouble
that is the sound of an airplane coming
over everybody sorry about that
[Music]
now I suppose the obvious question for
those of you who haven't been watching
for a long time yes where are the
Birmingham boys well at the moment we
think they are down south on the Sand
River probably close to the salubrious
environs of Elendil or Z or sing Gita or
mala mala very famous names there's Oh
reserved muddy as there since I was just
telling me that this mud on my jacket
now it's on his jacket and sorry about
that in fact there's more than that on
his jacket I didn't took us through some
fairly muddy patches earlier sorry about
that so I think that's where they are
and that whole in case you missed the
discussion that holes being created by
the demise of the long-standing
merging colonic coalition and so I think
that's left a void for the Birmingham
boys of probably two or three prides in
a very prey rich environment and I think
that's just where they're hanging out I
think it's probably a slightly more what
is it tastes to say a better choices of
territory but I think there's more
opportunity for them down there than
there is up here and so I think these
guys are just gonna drift in here
without too much of a fight
well as when you sit here all of us
wondering when they're going to get up
and do something
of course Lions can sleep for up to 20
hours of the day musty and so to say
that they would get up at any specific
time to go hunting
would be incorrect and I mean we have
set with flat cats deep into the evening
thinking well they're definitely gonna
get up now they're so hungry they must
start hunting now it's getting dark
they're definitely going to get up now
they're turning around and stretching a
little bit they're definitely going to
get up now I need to watch them fall
fast asleep again so it really is
difficult to say these guys look fairly
fat to me and I don't think they're in
need of a huge meal they could
conceivably sleep here for the rest of
the night but I suspect they will get up
as the Sun Goes Down and as it gets dark
and it meets check my time I mean that's
only gonna be the Sun will go down in
about 20 minutes or so now Juma is about
a thousand two hundred hectares chitwa
chitwa about eight hundred hectares so
that gives us a total traversing area of
200 hectares or about five thousand
acres and sorry I missed the name there
was a Jamelia Jamelia bromelia vanilla
vanilla like vanilla butter with a mix
up of the back letters very nice vanilla
yeah I so you know Juma and Chitra
together are not large enough to house
one pride in this area you'd probably
find a pride like the Inca Hamas has got
a territory of about eight to ten
thousand acres you know about what does
that say three and a half thousand
hectares or so and so Juma doesn't have
a number of prides but the boundary
between the sticks pride and the incomer
pride runs pretty much along the line
where those elephants were walking today
just south of an area called twinned air
and if I hadn't handed over the my map
to Steve I could show you where I meant
by that but it's it's you know you can
check it out on Google Earth if you want
you can see all of those landmarks and
and then there the ring proprietarily
goes way into the western north of us
and the Styx pride obviously we're in
the sticks part territory now remember
and this is very in be for anybody who's
interested in lions males are not part
of the pride and that's really important
for people to realize they are extra to
the pride they form a coalition like
this one here and in their domain will
fall anything between one and four
prides maybe in up to five perhaps in
some cases certain damaging Garner's at
least five in their territory these
chaps here at the moment if they do take
this territory will have the sticks and
the rumors and perhaps the Torchwood
pride as well that will be their domain
but a lot of their activity would take
place off juma our ralph has managed to
achieve the impossible he seems to have
found a puddle yes everyone I have
indeed found a puddle but it's a very
interesting panel at that it's got lots
of algae in it and that's probably as a
result of this little paddle pond being
in the full sunlight day in and day out
so it probably gets rather warm in the
water here but quite interesting there's
all sorts happening in this little pond
apart from the LD these little insects
on top of the water and that they
obviously aren't breaking the surface of
the water and they're able to run on top
and there's like little pond skaters and
midges but there is a little character
that we waiting for him to Pike his head
up any minute now above the surface of
the water because he needs to come up
for a breath so we just waiting for mu
and under little minutes ago I mean just
wait a little while and I'm sure he's
gonna pop up but there are all sorts of
insects nothing get the the pond skaters
as I mentioned but while we waiting for
him to pop his head head up little guy
yeah that's just in one of these little
tracks yeah and that's actually in the
check of the animal that I'm talking
about that we waiting for him to come up
so that is a little spider not sure the
exact kind it might be one of the little
fishing spiders Oh straight along the
surface of the water there now the
difference between an insect and a
spider spider well in arachnid and
they've got eight body parts and eight
sorry not eight body parts four body
parts versus three body parts of of the
of the insects as well as they've got
eight legs and the insects have got six
so a couple of little differences there
and that little spider there is one of
the more primitive of the two groups of
spiders we get my golem offs and Aranea
morphs Margalo morphs are the primitive
ones they don't build nests or webs they
M they stay on the ground and they
actively hunt out and they pray my
little car was doing there he was just
waiting there in ambush for maybe one of
these little midges to come along and
maybe it could catch it there Aranea
morphs and I build the webs and they
stay up almost vertical most of them but
some of them also and do hang upside
down and do all sorts of funny things
but it's our character that's going to
pop his head up lots of bubbles and that
can be all sorts of things and oxygen
being released out of the mat below with
the roots of the plants that are growing
in the area here that could be releasing
a little bit of oxygen and hydrogen and
he's now acting a little bit like Scuba
Steve
the hippo he's being all shy as soon as
we put the camera on come on
thank you heat up that DC don't just
walk past a little pond like this is all
sorts happening he's holding his breath
for quite a long time now surely okay
and I think we're out of luck he's given
us the slip as per usual
Just My Luck eh but anyway from one
little body of water to another off to
Steve yes sir we have managed to find
the gang of geese once again and if you
listen carefully you hear we be able to
get a flyby of a hammock open that was
it very easy to see he was just flying
straight Esther there but we are looking
at thick the gang of geese in a hostile
seven dad is nowhere to be seen now so
there's a concern but mom they're all we
think it's mom we've just been with them
as they just careened through the
beautiful green water in the afternoon
Sun and are they on the other side
drying themselves off in a very strange
place they could still be in the
sunshine if they were on the opposite
side of the dam but at least we know
that the parenting is going well she
seems to be looking left and right in
everywhere where his dead gone off to
has he gone for a cheeky one down the
road
Zeb giggles that knowing giggle of a
father herself just a quick cheeky one
Katherine Paulette yes they're still
seven we're going to try make a daily
thing try and catch up on these geese
and see how they were doing these are
the days of the geese lives the teams
and they go again fantastic
we were hoping for that oh we've got our
one hippo here who doesn't want to lose
any thunder he wants to be the star of
the show as well and chances are if we
keep the frame on him he will not do
that again
but the geese are cruising again
seems like absolutely no reason why they
went all the way across they're probably
left dad he was following and then mom
has looked back and be like dad has
slipped us there we go she calling
what's she doing
dad has slipped slipped the geese and
he's off wow they're making a noise okay
I don't know you wanna know the gender
of Egyptian geese up never actually
spend any time trying to identify male
and female my voice just noticed that
the the female or that they all seem to
hang around one so I'll have a look I
don't think there is a difference I just
I can't remember it let me tell you now
no okay so basically the male is larger
with a thicker neck and it's definitely
the call and the female is smaller with
a slimmer neck so it's very hard to say
but they do have a different call the
male is not as loud and raucous as the
females call but they look the same the
only reason I think or say a female is
because the youngsters seem to be
hanging around closer two to one so I
could only assume it's a mum so sorry
okay I can't give you any definitive
answers there well we moved off from
tandy and Cubs just to allow other
vehicles a moment I thought it would
come and check on their the geese and
the lone hippo Andrea I'm not sure how
long they'll stay with the parents but a
couple months or so they off they are
looking after themselves were there any
feeding themselves and during their ad
feeding she's just keeping a watchful
eye but soon they'll fledged and they'll
get bigger and about to fend for
themselves and go off and find a mating
pair for themselves for their life but
Nick definitely the next few months or
so so we're going to leave you head back
to tending out with some nice afternoon
Sun and let's go to something flatter
than the water James and
well there's some movement there
everybody the airplane is taking off and
it has disturbed this male lion
who opened his eyes and then moved his
head downwards and then flicked his ear
or sensors heart rate is through the
roof he can barely control his
excitement David tried to climb off the
car in terror at the lion moving his ear
like that I had to save them and Luke
who's a new director of course says that
that would be great idea to do an
unscheduled broadcast to Facebook with
these lions because the sighting is so
action-packed
I couldn't agree more Luke let's go live
to every page we can this is not a
sighting you're going to see very often
you will seldom see such impressive
sleeping skills on anything other than
either a wild earth presenter or a
deeply drunk teenager
lovely you want to know about the names
of these cats and in fact I think last
week during our show there was some name
suggested what were they they were um I
forget exactly what they were they were
quite funny there we named them after
Eva's that's right it was there we go
guacamole chip and dip that is not an
official name of these animals they are
not called guacamole chip and if they
have yet to be named and I think we
should probably get on to that process
fairly soon
we should possibly named them after
different synonyms for sleep slumber
passed out
did she call me namu I always laugh when
I hear that name because I'm not sure if
you realize me now move
maybe you've named yourself after this
Afrikaans cartoon that I used to watch
as a child yeah it was called minimal
and the the theme tune stuck in my head
and will be forever lamentably so um
they will get their full Mane's probably
in about three years or so they will
start to look full maimed in about a
year and a half or so I guess that'll
probably be when you'd expect them to
have the good sort of burning incised
mouths but they'll keep growing for the
rest of their days so that's what will
happen there
so I'm not sure where the third one is
and we've also that chaps just flicking
his tail I'm just gonna move everyone
because there are two other vehicles
here and I just want to get up away
otherwise no one else is gonna be able
to see them as I do that the question of
Cubs has been raised by Sharron and
whether this lot would be able to sire
Cubs yes technically they have the
equipment and the maturity to sire Cubs
at this stage but whether or not they
would be able to convince a prior two
females to allow that are not really
sure
I still can't see number three anyway
that's what's going on here all I'm
saying there is that until they take
over territory until the pride females
decide that they are going to accept
them as may well they don't have to
accept them but until they are able to
kind of impose themselves on the prime
they won't breathe then No okay what
kind of car is that
I've converted Ford it's quite nice
all right everybody I think that's let's
leave at the moment simply because
there's quite a lot of pressure being
brought to bear on them so let's just
head out we'll try and come back perhaps
when it gets a bit darker and we'll see
if they don't get up
and while we head out of here they do
have these wispy sort of teenager ish
type Mane's they're not that wispy
they're getting them and tell you I
think they're probably pretty similar to
the main sizes of the birmingham's of
the same age I'm just trying to remember
we didn't meet the Birmingham roughly
the same age but means I think a little
bit older than these guys when we first
met them but roughly the same age sure
and roughly the same kind of name so it
was just a bit too much pressure going
on there because they were in that big
thicket and I think we were hemming them
in so I just thought let's just head out
of here all right here we're gonna go
down towards trickle down and see if we
can't pick up some alarm calls from
hosts on our pants
now look at this everybody there is a
lot of NC er up on the tops of these
grass stalks they're not they look like
they might be cocktail insist I'm not
cold and they're not cooking the the
abdomen upwards they cohere downwards
this is a strange species of ants and
they're doing strange things here as
well I'm not quite sure what they're
doing initially I thought they were
gathering the seed husks or the seeds
from the grass but now doesn't look like
they are you know normally the ants are
very very important for the ecosystem
because they won't gather a lot of seeds
and they take it down underground and
they do feed on the husk and leaving the
seed behind and then you've got all
these seeds that remain in chambers
underneath the ground and if they are
times of drought well tell you they can
be even past ten years can pass and if
there then is some rain you've got from
these pockets of seeds that the ends of
stored below the ground you can have the
revival of of many different grass
species but what these guys are doing
now I'm not quite sure some of them are
carrying other ends and a moment ago we
did see a procession of much' billy ants
come across the road now I'm wondering
if these guys have all climbed up on top
of the top of these grass stalks and so
on to get away from them because matter
Billy ants are ruthless as the name
suggests matter Billy was an offshoot of
the Zulu tribe but they as that tribe
moved through southern Africa they
decimated all the try all the villages
and tribes that they came across so the
the matter Billy ends are quite similar
in what they do they also decimate all
the little other ends that they find
ants and termites and they steal all
their eggs and and pupae and they'll eat
that Linda I agree with you absolutely
amazing aunties and it's very cool and
would we do without them I am they you
know people think that sometimes they
pests in their garden because they you
know they do cut a lot of the grass and
son-in in little patches but it's still
we need them to you know keep the
balance in the ecosystem and there's so
many different species of ends that we
know nothing about and also the
communication is one of the most complex
of all the animal kingdom and in fact in
the world bees and ants and these kind
of air and little creatures have got the
most complex communication system it's
all about smells and dances and how you
move etc they've got a cost system so
you've got soldiers you've got workers
you've got reproductives and everybody
just selflessly selflessly Leslie goes
about their business and their job and
it just works like clockwork nobody
complains everybody just does their job
it's it's um it's quite interesting my
little boy watches bee movie quite
regularly and yes sorry can you just
repeat that question for me I'm just I'm
asking for a question Ivy's got a
question for us and I just wanted now
Ivy you want to know if they ever raced
well that's a very good question I don't
think that they're completely raced no
but I do there is a definite time of a
very low activity and because there are
also ectothermic so every when it's very
cold
they are very you know they don't have
much activity at all I do still move
around though but as they warm up and
then they will have more activity and
that's often why they stay under the
ground because then they maintain their
a warmth and they can then also keep the
activity up below the surface of the
soil our tower on top these and so all
doing strange things
yes my little boy he watches b-movie
quite regularly is a little three year
old and he loves Barry B and it's it's
just a very I think it's a fascinating
movie it just really pines puts it into
perspective as well you know in a very
humorous way but the cost system and how
things just just done without
questioning hey and I think ends very
similar as well as wasps but ants and
bees pretty complex
I love app good question they're queens
they can live for many many years
because they've fed and they fattened up
and I've heard that they can even live
over ten years and a colony is all
dependent on having a queen so if if a
queen is getting in trouble or I'm
getting sick and not producing properly
while the colony is is then sick as a
whole so it's very important for them to
also maintain and get more reproductive
now look at IV yeah there's a lot of
them all on top of these little flower
pods it's really interesting and they
don't seem to be doing anything obvious
that is very intriguing indeed and well
everyone from those exciting little
critters we're gonna head off down the
road and see what else we can find but
very exciting Steve's found something
wonderful for you if we have and she
seems to have wrestled away the
remainder of the steam buck caucus from
Columba and there is no sign of the
little devil anyway we are back on the
scene the other vehicles have since left
and just in time to spot her before the
night shrouds over and I have no doubt
this would be the final feeding she has
on this little carcass
there's not too much there she keeps
turning up and sticking up ahead and
looking around it's a vulnerable time
for her I healers are lurking well they
were this morning anyway and this is the
time they would come back again but she
is right at the base of a morula tree
she could spring up there in seconds and
that is why they choose to to feed at
the base of trees like that if they
don't heist so that they can't escape if
they need to they're very alert and see
her ears are always checking every sound
in the background Martha how many
leopards can live in an area you would
like to know well that all depends on
the food resource and the habitats
availability and I mean we have the
potential to see 9 or 12 leopards in and
around this area so it's a marvelous
number there is an enormous number of
small animal species in the form of
scrub hairs
Steinbach Dacre Impala so the food
availability is is really really good
that's what enables us to have so many
so many spotted cats in one place but
all depends on the resources and the
fact is that the habituation of leopards
have been going for so long that we know
the leopards and find them all the time
so they're quite relaxed so we get to at
least account for how many lepers there
are there's other reserves I've been to
that you can't you don't know how many
lepers or because they're not relaxed so
Benjamin these leopards are related to
the leopards in Southeast Asia actually
subspecies and there's not too much
different in them I think there's maybe
a small bit of weight in in the let the
Indian leopard but I think comparatively
they're pretty much the same thing it's
just separated by geographical time but
then do you know we've also got a
species of lipid down in the Cape in
South Africa that is exactly related to
this but genetically they are much
smaller and that's because their prey
food is far smaller in size about half
the size of these guys so they're very
very small the cape leopard although
they are the same
species but just through geographical
separation and food availability and
food size they've evolved to be a much
smaller cat how beautiful is sheep
she's very alert very very alert master
see you Tandy it's been some time
she's even more alert because she's got
a cub somewhere around here so she'll be
wondering what it's up to first of all
but we have seen her climbing she climbs
the trees pretty well so if anything did
happen to spook her she would
immediately get up into the safety of
the tree canopy and interestingly enough
we don't see too many male leopards on
this side of the property I think gajima
occurs the sad happens above us hook not
that I've ever seen him before but also
because the vegetation is so thick here
very hard to really figure out where the
leopards are coming and going on I
eastern boundary beautiful habitat for
them
okay well it seems like James has left
his lines but I believe he still and
Chitra so let's go see what he's up to
we're having the most wonderful time
here at the waterhole watching the baby
hippos there all of whom too small to
leave their mothers sort of a few months
ago
now living in this little pod in the
shallows next to that Island and I think
we're about six of them and they're
having such a fun little play that one
was just yawning a little bit one
sticking his tongue around I've been
pushing each other about and the one the
biggest one closest to us I think is a
sort of sub adult and he's just kind of
watching over these chaps and bullying
them a bit from time to time there's
ones underneath thee underneath that I
think that thing's fallen over a bit as
well in fact it definitely has that tree
that those guys are playing around with
I think they've been digging away slowly
unintentionally at its base and it
started to lean heavily you might also
be able to get those kingfishers can you
simple well done
fired kingfishers this is called
advanced camera work everybody this is
not for the faint at heart there we go
he's even gone with a super zoom good
grief he's feeling brave this evening
well done since all excellent job so
there's the pied kingfishers obviously
having some kind of a spat it is Sunday
night of course the pressures of the
week starting to build and they're all
of course talking about you know what
they have to do o green-backed heron
beautiful spot their sins all
disappeared over the back of the dam
wall go back to the hippo pop to mine
now I don't know about any of you and I
think I've said this to a few of you
before but my very worst feeling as a
child was Sunday evenings the thought of
going back to school after a fun weekend
especially as winter started to take
ahold of Johannesburg really was deeply
miserable and actually used to get a
kind of nauseous feeling in my belly and
it is such a magnificent feeling every
Sunday evening out here when I realize
and remember even though I left school
some 25 years ago it's such a great
feeling to know that tomorrow I just get
to do the same fun stuff again just look
at these little chaps under the base of
the tree there now how they're too cute
now you can see that those hippos are
standing there and I've said to you
often that hippos cannot swim as have
all of the guides and Cathy it's got to
do with their density they just sink
they don't float it's not that they
can't swim in by that I mean it's not
it's not that they have an inability to
swim it's that they sink and it's so
that they can stay under the surface
without sort of trying to if you know
what I mean they can stay safe under the
surface so where they're standing there
they will just be able to kind of lie
down and not float to the top which you
couldn't do you would struggle to do
that they can absolutely move under the
deep in the deeper water and they run
along the bottom and then push
themselves up to the top take a breath
and then sink down again elephants as
far as I understand it can float in fact
I'm I'm not convinced they can actually
I'm not convinced an elephant can swim
like say a horse can swim you hear
stories of them crossing quite deep
water bird with their trunks out of the
water and I'm not sure if they're
walking on the bottom with they're
actually swimming I've now got myself a
bit confused so Kathy
and I feel like some of those islands in
Lake Kariba that the elephants go to and
from and in fact in this big lives am
busy river must indicate that they can
swim because I don't unless they do the
same thing that the hippos do just walk
along the bottom and push themselves up
I'm not sure so there's little things
having a great time
Kingfisher's having a spat still all the
action going on on that tree the dart
are sitting above there is some magical
evening
now of course no mammal is able to
breathe under the water and pan catch
the respiratory system of the animal is
exactly the same on water and on land
they can obviously hold their breath for
longer than you or I can and this you
were particularly good at holding your
breath I am NOT and they just I'm sure
they breathe pretty normally when
they're on land they don't have a a
different respiratory system it still
used uses the lungs yeah it does answer
your question I'm not sure if I'm
getting you correctly look how many
little things there are any fun fat
little crash of toddler hippos trying to
show how big their mouths are there are
some of the cutest animals out here one
of them just resting on his friends back
there he's retired after a strenuous
weekend Pied wagtail is the bird you too
Pied wagtail the two birds you can see
there
[Laughter]
they are I'll see I'm sure this is not
what you've asked but it sounded like
you asked if that nest was where the
hippo nest and the dead tree now hippos
don't make nests Marcy I'm being
facetious I know you didn't really mean
that that nest is an old red bull
Buffalo weavers nest Marcy you might
just be able to hear them going from
myriad other apartment blocks they've
built around the place
that one is disused at the moment so I
don't think the Pied wagtail x' nest in
there don't I if I'm not mistaken
they've missed in mud banks but I'm
going to check that for you because I
might be telling you a lie and that
would be terrible any time but
especially on Sunday evening let me have
a look-see wagga tale for camp I'd check
click habitat you can hear them giving
their little Sunday songs the hippos
oh no they breathe in a cup nest often
placed over water so they don't breathe
in mud so they could easily build their
little nest in that or underneath that
tree or on top of it there probably do
have a nest there let's check when they
breathe general habits foraging and food
breeding monogamous typically retains
made for successive reading attempts now
[Music]
we've been talking about the swimming
abilities of the large grey animals and
child of the universe of a Rhinos
swimming abilities I'm afraid I have
absolutely no idea David do you know 4
rhinos able to swim I would say no as
well I think they would almost certainly
sink in the same way that the hippo does
I've never seen arrived
paddling around in a water hole like
this have definitely seen elephants
cavorting around the Rhino no I've seen
them lying in mud but I've never seen
them try to swim so I don't know if
they're able to do the breaststroke or
the butterfly hmm gorgeous gorgeous seem
well here I'm going to make a cliched
link everybody it's becoming nighttime
and of course therefore time to put on
your pajamas put your pajamas on it is
getting right but there's another animal
that is like a donkey in pajamas with
its swooshing tail there and we're here
next to for your tailor damn so you can
probably see that zebra on the dam cam I
don't know if you could see us at the
moment hopefully we can a flaw just
enough in there and I think it's yeah
that you can't see us but zebra happily
grazing away next to the dam and the Sun
has gone down now so we're getting it
wonderful colors in the Scala now as
pinks and blues it is very very pretty
fantastic we're gonna start making our
way back towards camp because you know
we don't really want to be walking out
in a dock but I've had a thoroughly
enjoyable walk it's been great getting
into the nitty-gritty down with there
with all the small stuff and and just
investigating what has been going on
looking at all the texts and signs etc
and well I'm glad that you all joined us
on it it is always wonderful to be out
on foot and you should take up the
charts anytime you get if you come to
Africa because for me it is the best way
to experience the bush and well you can
just yeah and feel everything so much
better than on a vehicle so we're gonna
make our way back towards camp I think
that's probably it for us on on the bush
walk but they takes you back to James
bye for now
now very kindly I got on to my will not
very kind in my pod but I got on to the
tweeter while you were away and
immediately I knew somebody would have
found the odds for me Stacy you have
found a reference that says elephants
can swim
they swim completely submerged with
their head above the water and their
mouths below and use all four legs to
paddle so absolutely elephants can swim
very good news indeed
thank you very much can this fellow get
behind us since we're just putting on
the infrared light this is why we're not
zooming into anything and that's the
large finger sorry yeah with play-doh so
deeply offended this fellow like I've
just insulted his entire family
sometimes one is filled with an
insatiable rage and the desire to scream
out and tell somebody really what you
think of them unfortunately we are now
alive and I'm unable to do that so I
must just grin are you able to zoom that
camera anymore or you know you not there
we are good fantastic
I turn round I say to David David can he
get pastor David yes you can definitely
get past even a truck David says could
have got past sorry can you move please
can you move there please nasty piece of
work may his dinner be infested with
stink bugs this evening
now hippopotamus of course live in the
water and therefore Cecilia yes I
suppose you could call them aquatic
animal well they're Latin name of course
is hippopotamus amphibious and so I
suppose you'd call them amphibious
mammals rather than the classic ones I
suppose a truly aquatic mammal would be
something like a dolphin or a whale or a
porpoise or maybe maybe a seal would
also be considered amphibious so let's
call them amphibious mammals rather than
aquatic ones do you want to get in for
it is it necessary since all alright
Cinda would like to go to infrared oh
well he's thanks for the warning there
we go looky we're aiming for it if
you're wondering we're good
well done since all were you getting a
message there on your radio
you can see it really does pick up a
whole lot more life doesn't it and you
can almost see that young hippos tonsils
now he's eating the tree we can see
these youngsters playing around with
each other and having a bit of a game
and jumping on top of each other and I
think it's an interesting run read I
don't know if they ever try and drown
each other when they're having a fight
I'm sure these little ones aren't trying
to do that I imagine they're probably do
you know but I've never read anything
about that that's a really interesting
question would be very quick ways you
kill a rival wouldn't it I'm not sure
that they have the equipment you know I
mean if a human being is trying to drown
another human being they can stand in
kind of hulls morbid subject anyway they
can stand and hold their victims head
under the water but you know it's
difficult to see a scenario where one
hippos head would be under the water and
the other one wouldn't you know what I
mean yes there happened to be in the
perfect kind of depth of water and one
managed to stand on the others head I'm
gonna say no I don't think they're try
and drown each other this chap is not
going to spike his palate on that tree
just like with every single other mammal
species this kind of playground behavior
he's going to sit up the dominance
hiring hierarchy that will last probably
the rest of their lives I'm gonna move
on from here see what else we can find
as darkness falls the Civil War has not
had to find anything further and Tandy
has not done too much apart from just
munch munch munch away at her little
Steinbach that his left calamba has yet
to reveal her pretty face once again and
the light is fading the African night is
upon us
did you hear a call
she made a little call there last time
she did that play Lambert arrived pretty
soon on the scene but kinda get into
that time of night when you'd want your
children nearby before the scary's come
out in the night time me being one of
the scary's but as I'm on the cup to
adventures his little cats a very very
adventurous and I wish she's gone
but I'm sure she's somewhere nearby or
be chasing Franklin's or try to we
haven't heard them here we going that's
listen
let's see what she spotted I can hear a
taker a lot calling
might have been a Steinbach by the next
you know the difference between their
Lanka it was little bleating sound did
you hear that said safely got her ears
pricked up we're gonna stay with her see
what happens here itself Franklin in the
background what is there in the darkness
she's calling again for her cub
doesn't seem too concerned definitely
sound like something of their Esav save
almost thought it sound like a sneeze is
she coming
are there she comes just above my head
she's about to come and there she is
there she is
hello gorgeous we are in infrared folks
that's why it's looking quite green
well that's infrared now oh she's
stalking mum don't want to get my head
in the shot silver crunchy right down
here how that's the lumbar come and say
hello scratch on the neck this is too
precious
- too precious without the camera well
you can see his ears in the grass it's a
dark yet
yo shape of of a garfield head really
she can hear mum munching let's see what
she does she's trying to be very stealth
she's putting her paws down
it's all practice for the real thing
ma'am no she's coming though but she's
trying to be very stealthy don't he just
called again
Laura it is too precious indeed turned
his calling she wants you to come but
she's not a very obedient young cat but
a lot of the viewers have from there
named her rebel
I suppose when you're that small it is
just so innocent you don't know what
dangers there are out there
attendees moving past us now have come a
little Columba soul astral full belly
she's got their ton dear she moves on
she comes - is he's gonna investigate
what mum has left behind hello gorgeous
can't quite indeed perfection and
training and she's needs to learn
everything from mum who's now just
moving off having a toilet break so I
forget you asked the question earlier
about the lipids get more spots when you
look at Colombo there you can see she's
got plenty of spots but the spacing
between is probably just a little bit
little bit tighter packed than mum here
she is hello ma'am let mum no rest for
for parents even when they want to go to
the toilet the youngsters are always
very interested she is too cute
choy I didn't notice any wound on tannaz
chest armor she hasn't really shown
herself to us too clearly but there's no
obvious sort of sign in her behavior she
was lying on her chest
earlier she seems to be very comfortable
lying there that the youngsters having a
toilet break directly where mum was here
we go
not shy at all for the camera
to see little mini version of mum
okay well it looks like James is
watching the full moon rising we're
going to stay here let's go over to him
with his Luna I am indeed trying to
watch the full moon rising I didn't
realize it was going to be full today
but I think it is and there seems to be
a lot of gold dust spread about it
doesn't their sins oh do you think
perhaps there has been a oh you mean you
were in infrared at least yes are you in
color are we in color there yes look us
are you in color or useful in black and
white thank you very much for that
information
Luke it is apparently extremely harsh
where you're sitting watching it it's
quite LaRose where we are here beautiful
and it does look like it's been sprayed
about with gold dust I have some fairies
have become excited but on the Sunday
afternoon evening Sunday
we plan to go back to the Lions I don't
know if we're going to have another view
of them though that's how sort of our
plan I think they are moving and I think
they're moving quite close to the
western boundary of Chittoor which means
we might be able to follow them but
we'll do it a go and see what we come up
with variety we're going to go back into
infrared now look us no turns all we
have to tell them before you there just
do it wise I'm going to get it in the
neck tomorrow at morning meeting
okay yes that's a relief Luke Luke is
very understanding unlike some I mean
some you would do that to it'll be in
trouble for me
bangle and you say wow South Africa gets
to have a moon and then you confused
yourself by being surprised by this yes
we have a moon and in fact it's got a
nice story around this as we drive
hopefully towards those lines there was
a great sunset once and there was a
German guest on the back of a vehicle
and there was a number of South African
guests and South African guests were
often some of the worst guests we had
because they felt the need to impress
everybody with the paucity of Bush
knowledge and this guy said there's the
Sun went down it has we've shown you
many times is take a picture take a
picture of that though all the Sun of
the sunset it's gorgeous
take a picture take a picture and
eventually this German turned him and
said he has the Sun in Germany as well
you know and it goes down there also
which I thought was a very salient point
not these lines are mobile
I'm afraid unfortunately I think there
are too many people here let me just try
and figure out what's going on here
let's go across to Steve while I do that
well first of all little Columba
followed her mom's direction and had a
little toilet break exactly where she
did and we are now parked right next to
it which is marvelous I must say and
then mom started giving her proper
grooming hmm it's ok tündi we haven't
done anything she hasn't looked at us
like that at all and suddenly she just
looks at us like that in the darkness
with her teeth she's having herself a
bit of a groom and she was given Colombo
a bit of a lick down and I think the
youngster is is over there grooming and
wants to start moving now she's
definitely full of energy full of beans
you would say and I've no doubt that
they'll be on the move shortly probably
in search of some water she's extras
behind this bush said we won't get her
if you jest there in the darkness behind
the bush and we won't get her no she's
just sitting there and I'm not going to
move any further Ford without chasing
Tandy
katelyn African Wildcats most certainly
buried their dung like normal cats but
leopards do not lie and do not sir will
do as well but I've never seen a leopard
do it I've seen leopards cover the the
carcass before or the stomach content of
something they're killed with sand but
not not not there not there done I don't
know why it's just the way it is why do
cats domestic cats do it I don't know
why either to be a secretive perhaps no
idea and know what the purposes she is a
mom I want to be the star of the show I
wonder if she realizes how many people
absolutely love her she's got enormous
ears almost like her older brother
Kumbha Owen if she's going to grow it to
those years he still hasn't grown into
his ears
sandesh I don't think so I think she
knows she raises the Cubs exactly the
same it's all about feeding them keeping
them safe there's no real sex
to them for a long time so the male of
Asti gets bigger then the female
requires a little bit more food later on
and maybe becomes a bit more competitive
with mum sorry about the front of my car
this is live folks these cats are doing
what they need to do right in front of
us and I'm not going to start the car to
chase the way that little youngster but
I don't think there's any difference in
how a parent will raise a cup I think
they just do what they do I mean for
example she's been in very similar areas
I believe two previous litters am i
right zip yes
yeah same areas same sort of strategy
you know feed hoist train them keep them
safe she's very interested in me I said
I think last night someone said she's
got a good pea heart enormous ears
enormous ears she's looking right at
Sabre I think she's got a a fetish for
cameramen because last night I heard
Brent said that she was looking at
Dharavi now she's looking it's the best
job hmm also trying to figure out
they're very inquisitive you know she
knows that that we're not a threat
because mums allowed us into the space
and she hasn't reacted in any way no see
how she keeps looking back at mum mums
relaxed but this has been going on for
months
that's how leopards are easily
obituaries obituaries because they seem
to learn very quickly my mum's not
bothered I'm not going to be too
bothered but they still inquisitive they
still want to have a little sniff a
little feel all these weird the plethora
of smells coming off the vehicle this
diesel is oil brake fluid oh there we go
I want some more licking mum not done
with the grooming yet that's too
precious
it's too precious
David you want to know if staying with
him after dark puts him in danger if the
cab was on its own certainly but we we
are not using any lights we will not be
using any lights at all and tandi's here
the mothers here says absolutely no
problem but yeah we're not going to be
staying for very much longer and if they
move very far we won't be staying well
we still actually got shot over half an
hour so darker Eddy but if the cub was
on her own we would not be here at all
we would have left already but we're not
attracting any attention we're not using
any lights if she's scratching yes it I
think yeah she's here scratching
somewhere we can hear her
so you're definitely viewing Cubs off
the dark is a big no-no and putting a
spotlight on a cub after dark is a very
big no-no even putting spotlights on on
predators really but it's kind of being
moved away from but is there scratching
was that bones I think she's got more of
the Steinbach just over there can we
just look over half the cub is in front
of me still seven and then I'll move
okay there's no cub over here see I
can't see that area folks it is it is
dark that it sounds like she's found the
remainder of her Steinbach so let's just
inch
oopsie okay the hyenas have just emerged
into the scene here and that would chase
a cat straight up the tree there's a
hyena that I mean is going to take the
kill there it is and it'll be very
silent about it won't tell anybody see
that hyena came out of nowhere but it
would have known she was here this
morning
but it has not caught any of the cats
it is only caught
the remainder of whatever tending he was
munching on I'm just gonna move around
the corner here I heard that move off a
Haina just moved off yeah I heard the hi
in Iran
ayane is in front of my car now trying
to figure out where these lipids have
gone
yes oh boy no no no this is part and
parcel of what happens out your folks so
it's probably good to just have the
vehicle off and listen I have no doubt
that the lipids are safe the hyenas
moving around it's moving to the last
tree it was at where the remains of the
Steinbach are
very good chance that the cat's bolted
off or climbed a tree but we haven't
quite spotted them yet we don't want to
disturb the scene well they let them all
be safe
not much left for you there young hyena
less apparently a lot of viewers can
identify these cars I wouldn't know how
to identify you know I'm just gonna go
forward yeah okay I don't know where
they're gone
I heard as said mentioned the hyenas are
coming in that the leopards bolted off
and I thought they bolted straight for
this tree up ahead yeah but we will see
amazing amazing a vanishing act just
like that they disappeared but I am sure
they are here somewhere they might have
even just walked away and in moments
lipids vanish into the darkness
okay well while we search for these
beautiful cats let's go back over to
James with his boo I'm just waiting
everyone for a little space to open up
in the lion sighting they did get moving
towards the west so I didn't think we'd
be able to see them but they're now not
moving there are three people there
already and they've said that I can come
when one of them leaves and that means
you can come this exciting temperatures
dropping slowly it's probably now about
72 degrees also Fahrenheit so it's not
exactly freezing
but certainly winter is on the way we're
also in the vicinity where horse Han are
was yesterday Oh Paula that nearly
answered your question for you it was
almost never you want to know when we're
going to get you're going to get to meet
David I'm hoping around about the 2nd of
May I shall unleash him on you oh here
we go hang on a second everybody go
ahead
Koby thanks I'll make my way
all righty we're on our way
all right goody steve has been
successful
yes well she she just went straight up
the tree she was originally in with the
Steinbach but we just listening out
she's called twice for the cub and the
cub is not materialized I'm gonna
probably slack away and is hiding behind
has been too busy with the remains of
that Steinbach to have noticed the cub
so don't worry folks
the Cubs instinct is to to hide away or
climb up a tree sorry about that
she is listening there we go she's
calling
pema faxes is 100% life cannot predict
what will happen next
Alicia yeah the cub and mom were
grooming and the hyena came out of
nowhere and mum just launched herself
into the tree and I don't know what
there's another hyena coming in here
from the right I mean a right underneath
her there listen to her hissing at it
this is incredible folks I don't know if
it's a different hyena what's the same
one to walk around sniffing
this is incredible folks you can almost
see the concern on her face they're very
strong feeding the cub is perfectly fine
it's just being very quiet it wouldn't
come to her now if she called obviously
because they are hyenas lurking around
so ever it is secret away
and once the hyenas lose interest from
the smell and the bones that they've
eaten they will move off in search of
another scrap or meal somewhere else
yeah Luke I don't see the hyena anymore
I think that little piece we saw there
is about as action riddled as it might
be
that's the waiting game
not just bear in mind focus it this
happens probably every night to these
cats that's why they live in trees spend
a lot of their time in trees to be safe
from the marauding hyenas I mean she's
only half a meter or meter off the
ground she's she's actually that's the
grounders they're probably about a foot
from below her foot so she's not very
well protected from the heina but she's
very quick you might have seen that clip
on Saturday of husana climbing that tree
ridiculously fast up a tree
okay I'm Cathy I'm gonna answer your
question I'm just gonna move forward a
meter so that you can get her face
just in a little bit of a hole Kathy you
corner up your head around why Lippert
is scared of a hyena well hi Hina has
the most powerful bite for an animal of
its size and if I ain't it happened to
Bart Andy on her leg or anywhere really
it might not kill her but it would
definitely [ __ ] her ability to hunt
and climb a tree which is basically a
death sentence so any leopards on
encountering anything is calling in the
background when encountering anything
like a hyena
okay well we'll carry on with what I'm
talking about in moments but it's gotta
James who's found his lions while you
were all asking if these lions are
calling at the moment and they have
started to call this one here is just
making sort of perfunctory perfunctory
rules
[Music]
all those you answer everybody here
vocal boys are here to stay there is no
clearer announcement or male lion
claiming a territory than that that's
two of them we don't know where the
third one is was that not spectacular
now we're not gonna be able to stay here
long there are quite a few people trying
to get into the siting obviously because
now these lions are calling which means
that you know if you ever visit Africa
of course and so one thing of God really
wants to show you so we'll sit you
another few minutes and just see if we
don't get lucky with another call just
gonna ask on the radio how many standbys
there are
how many stations on standby for this
evoke a male sighting I'm just trying to
find out how many on standby
sorry just go again or that I can't hear
ok copy Thanks
just give me another three minutes here
and I'll pull up
how now what these other guys are doing
is going around to see if they can't
find the other one so I don't include in
any tearing rush to leave will hang
around for a few minutes also we did get
here lost
oh so we don't need to leave just yet
because they're looking for the third
one no I didn't hear but apparently he
was also calling now that's a pretty
loud sound and if you're sitting next to
it it can really rattle your ribcage
that's the big sort of analogy that
everyone gives Jason it can probably be
heard by a lion up to I would say 10 to
15 kilometers as the crow flies and
maybe not quite that far let's call it
ten kilometers as the crow flies human
being I think you'll hear them on a cool
morning you know I think I'll easily
hear them for about five kilometres or
so maybe even further than that in fact
let's say five to ten kilometres for
human being ten to fifteen for lion
obviously their ears are a lot more
sensitive a nozzle this is good news it
looks like we can stay these guys are
leaving and as they leave the there are
another two groups looking for the other
lion so we can just stay here
hello
let me move forward to you everybody
sorry
thanks guys sorry I missed that
you look us can we have it again
better I've sent now that calling as I
was saying Johnson is an advertisement
to say this is our territory we're
taking over here and it's in it just to
basically say to all the other lions in
the area this is ours and you'll find
lions throughout the night and the
various territories of the Kruger
National Park we'll be doing exactly
what these three have done but younger
than this you will find that they will
not be calling they won't call because
they want to stay under the radar these
guys have now broken cover and said okay
anybody thinks this land is theirs then
there must come and challenge us first
because we are laying down the challenge
we made just a witnessed the passing of
the age of the Birmingham boys over here
not so much with an enormous fight and a
scratch and a bite but with a little bit
of a wimp up the birmingham's have just
moved on these guys have come into an
unoccupied territory and find themselves
with great luck give them a chance to
call once more and then we can move out
and what is so fascinating is that we
there's been a lot of research done on
lion voices and whether or not
individual lions can be recognized by
other lions and pixel no question about
it
in Kahuna's and the sticks prides will
not recognize these as Birmingham owls
they will know that they are not berming
a male's of they are not the same
they will just see if they call again
and I know you can probably hear a lot
of radio noise have someone our vehicle
that's on the other two vehicles just
fantastic stuff to hear that sound that
it's been a very long time since I've
heard that especially at that proximity
and so exciting to be around here for
this take over or shall we say
replacement only take over could be a
strong term right I believe that as
steve has got good news yes we do
looks like Columba has made it back to
the tree she's not giving mummy some
well-needed attention any mom smile for
the camera
take your screen shots now mm-hmm says
she just materialized again out of the
darkness she came into the tree she gave
mum a little sniff thought about going
higher up into the tree and then thought
better of it and thought now let's
continue the grooming who doesn't
blackhead scratches when I do
mmm-hmm isn't that just too precious
now what
yes Kathy our to get back onto that if a
leopard gets bitten by a hyena
that's over for them really so they'd
rather avoid it rather avoid it hyenas
are very tough resilient characters and
if but they've got such powerful bites
you know a leopard attacking hyena
probably might even kill it because iene
is a very tough but one but minor and
the leopard the ability to climb is is
over so that is the reason it's an
evolutionary adaptation to to move away
and then come back I've seen leopards
kill things and then I inna submerge on
the scene and the leopard leaves
immediately it assesses what's going on
and then comes back I've seen often male
leopards come back and chase the hyena
off the kill but the reason they move is
they don't have time to contemplate hood
is that's running in from the darkness
it could be lions it could be another
leopard it could be a clan of hyenas so
essentially they have to move off
reassess the situation then it come back
but for a female leopard to take on
hyena it's just not worth the risk so I
hope that answers your question Kathy I
think one on one in a fight I mean it's
got just such a powerful bite
well Clifford we were sitting here we
could hear those Avoca males calling
from Shippuden we could hear them and
she just lay there very nonchalant very
non caring so I don't we were wondering
said when our talking what do you think
they're do well do leopards do and she
did absolutely nothing she just lay
there so I suppose that the purpose of
the calling at least lets you know where
they are and she'll know how far away
there are and it won't be concerned to
her that's the animal you don't hear
calling that's the concern because you
don't know where they are but when they
advertise themselves it's a very obvious
sort of beacon for where they are and
other lions they'll see it with with the
females that goomer pride will be
hearing them call and they'll get up and
move in the opposite direction hopefully
that's not further south from where
they're where maybe they'll push them up
here in to Juma who we probably see in
the next few days it's been sitting with
prides of lions and the males called in
the north of the south and the Lions get
up and they're walked in the opposite
direction I've seen that many many times
but a leopard doesn't have anything to
really fear of the male lions apart from
if they do interact lions aren't looking
to seek out the lipids for mating or for
any purpose like that for territory so
the feet the leopards will just avoid
them as much as they can they're no
match for a lion no match for male lions
or and it's in this exact area that the
berming one of the birmingham boys
actually climbed up a morula tree
earlier this year and stole two of
Tandy's kills that she left in the tree
that was there when they would go the
black shoes do some simple walking this
it she's trying to be mum a little wiry
tail that's probably in response to the
fact that there are INR out there
the youngsters kind of moved on to the
spot where the hyena were and it did a
little bit of like a territorial scrape
no Linda don't go anywhere we don't have
too many minutes left of the show and
we're gonna see if we can keep up with
these two I can't even see them sabes
got them on the camera when I'm looking
okay should we move up there okay we're
going to move up so that we don't lose
them in the darkness
stay with us though folks
they are some big termite mounds in and
around here so bear with us if we
suddenly disappear down a hole okay
while we try and reposition for these
two there she is in the trees maybe got
it sorry sorry she climbed up a tree and
now she's down Tandy's just here on the
left there she is
okay she is just in the long grass
licking her lips what direction are you
two going to go towards a quarry pan
perhaps for some light drinking this is
when it really gets fun trying to follow
them in this at night Sid laughs under
his breath you knows how hard it is but
we will attempt the impossible
okay so we try stay I've put them here
seems like James has managed to refine
some signal so while we try to keep up
with these two let's go back over to him
what we're trying to do is find the
third Avoca male we heard him calling in
here he sits the proverbial lion amongst
the Impala
he's somewhere here we must have driven
straight past him I've driven this road
already today you so flat deep in the
grass anyway he was yelling just in here
there's a small and frightened scrub
here I could be moving or he could be
sort of trying to get the others to come
towards him I would have said he was
right here there's a noise is that him
and I'm sure many of you rather like me
most impressed by your first sighting or
sounding of an Avoca male or raw most
impressive it was especially given that
they're not the biggest fellows yet
yeah I can see how little vehicle
activity and I wonder this is obviously
where they found the third one this
morning
so he's around here somewhere
yelling his head off he's not yelling at
the moment of switch your theories we
got him we got the third one
hooray let me just turn the car hello my
friend we'll turn off the lights we'll
look at you an infrared - don't worry so
he's about I'd say about how far did we
think away would we say the others are
for about 400 meters quarter of a mile
now I'd be very interested to know if
any of you think this one is slightly
larger or slightly smaller than the
other two because what I think is quite
interesting is that there's different
disparate in this coalition already
there were the two of them and then this
guy on his own when we saw them on foot
it was two together yeah the guy was
away and I wonder if he isn't slightly
older it looks to me like his main
extend slightly further down his back
and I wonder if he perhaps comes from a
different world and would mean he
probably comes from a different mother
maybe the other two are litter mates and
this guy's a cousin he's looking a bit
forlorn at the moment but he gave a
wonderful call that CB goes again
and I just must I mean I just said the
same thing as Murphy's asked I said I
wondered if he he was the lead in then I
realize of course it's not it's not
really what happens in these coalition's
there's no real leader at all they just
kind of go about their business and
there's no obvious dominant well in
theory that's what the textbooks will
tell you showed me some textbooks but
when I think back to the matte umber
males who were the group before the
Birmingham's one was definitely bigger
than the other and he seemed to
monopolize the mating opportunities so
to say that he wasn't the dominant or
you know more more dominant male I think
would be wrong but whether he was the
leader or not when he made the decisions
I don't know
for big you're just listening for the
others perhaps wondering if the Avoca
mails are calling or not and not the
ever come as the Birmingham's and Chris
I don't it really depends where the
Birmingham's are whether they could hear
him or not I'm not gonna try and follow
him through this thicket everybody
I believe that Steve oval was managed to
get himself stuck in a hole so you gonna
stay with us for now okay
well I think that was a great line
sizing we'll start with very weakly with
that rather pathetic sleeping sighting
we had and ended very strongly I'm sorry
we didn't get him calling
and one of the things that made the
merging galan coalition so very strong
was the fact that they seemed to come
together every time there was trouble
now that's unusual and Sammy Jane you
say will they split they could easily
split yes but a coalition of threes a
small coalition so in a coalition afford
to find two and two together which again
the matin bus did they were fall and
then there were two and two it's not
unusual to find them splitting but I
think in a coalition of three I really
don't think that's going to happen I
think it's much more likely that they
will stay together we might know we
won't absent or G signal we should be
fine over here
now remember we are having a time change
it's not tomorrow it's the day after I
think isn't it because today is the 29th
and this I've gone mad
correct Luke
okay good so the time change will occur
on Tuesday morning we will move 1/2 hour
later to escape the darkness in the
morning and 1/2 hour earlier in the
afternoon so we'll be going live at 6:30
Central African time in the morning and
then again at 3:00 o'clock Central
African time in the afternoon so that is
how the changes will occur
the birds knocking about here some water
thick knees and we're gonna shine on
them we'll give you a last look at
chitta lodge and the moon gorgeous stuff
all right everybody that's going to be
it from us today a marvelous marvelous
afternoon we've had of cats a marvelous
weekend and most encouragingly my Monday
morning will be spent doing exactly what
all my other mornings are doing thank
you very much for joining us it's been
an absolute joy having you with us I'm
not sure what sins I was doing and till
tomorrow morning
xx and happy wherever you are in the
world